everything that we do with alma mater is
gonna always be timeless classic luxury
right these are classics when people
live and die by these models the dna of
everything that i understand is just my
childhood like it's all nostalgia
what's good gq my name is james whitner
owner and founder whitaker group this is
my life and sneakers
[Music]
the start was like as a retailer right
you get in and you got a perspective and
it was that social status i think it was
like oh 405 oh [ __ ] that's when i opened
that's when that's when it kind of like
the idea hit me like oh i think i could
put this in a pot make it come together
they started to realize like i had a
really unique point of view
so the design process for the aj1 once
we get the story right and we know what
models we're working on we just cook we
go back and forth uh they bring in the
rest of the extended team men who work
on boxes and leathers and then we just
start
pulling materials
um to get to a place the aj1 didn't
start off as crackle leather it started
off as like this tumbled leather and
then we kept saying like that ain't it
like how do we push it and we came up
with the cracked leather and it just
just looks incredible
when looking at this shoe right
especially what's happening now with
with vintage
and and kids wanting their shoes to feel
worn that's another reason why the
cracked leather was so important right
because it was a way to speak to where
youth culture is now and still
maintaining the ethos of ammonia and
what we want to do the other thing was
unstrapping the wing
from from the upper because i'm not like
a folded kind of jean kind of dude right
for me when i wear a one i want my
bottoms to sit somewhere by unleashing
the flap it gives you the ability to
style the shoe a bunch of different ways
and it doesn't limit you to just like
one way or another like messing with the
tongue the rest of it is like yo the
one's a classic like who are we kidding
[Music]
oh
jordan 3
air force one
oh jordan 11.
um
it starts to get fuzzy after that you
need two more
my error
my error
says the air max one because nautica
sweats and air max ones in the 90s is
like
it's a thing even though you can't you
people people remake that thing
um
i'll probably say after that
jordan force
the jordan 4 is so
[ __ ] classic yo now you could wear it
up you could wear it down you could wear
it with sweats you could wear with so
when you just think about just getting
fly threes and fours you can take to so
many different places
i grew up 80s 90s so mj was was coming
out the first time i think mj was the
first athlete that connected sneakers
and culture so
seeing him
and the swag that he had on the court
and what he'd done on the court and
jordan's dropping at that time with the
aj3 being one of the first ones that
i've ever owned like yo like getting
that shoe in that moment it definitely
you know you connect to you connect to
what you see i think that was some of
the feeling that you got at the time
because at the time mj was
the biggest thing in the world
what's something that's meaningful
it speaks to the influence
but it also speaks to our culture
and and that's how i came up with alma
mater i hit one of my homies that was
french and was just going through
different words because i french has
always inspired luxury right and then it
was like for me it was
uh
black culture
and french right so
alma mater means my way in french so
it's our culture our culture's way so
it's our culture's expression of luxury
[Music]
when we started the idea of a year in
2012 people kind of thought we were
crazy thinking like what people want to
experience luxury this way but now and i
think i'm zero shocked
that did sneakers go for a thousand
dollars let's just backtrack
i'm from whitaker projects
right so the ethos of everything that i
connect to got something to do with the
four wolves and in my journey and
getting out of those projects it's
culture it's black culture being built
through lived experiences it's not just
about singularity about retail it's
about us telling our stories and pushing
the idea of what we're about and why and
how to bring each other along
product is king
but story's queen happy wife happy life
right so in order to in order to make
products stand stronger you got to tell
meaningful stories when you have those
two things and they go together
perfectly you have a happy marriage we
wanted to tell a story of airness and
and the idea of airness is something
that you said is our culture being taken
from us and soul back to us like so many
times our culture is taking soul back
with no gain no gain to us and the story
airedness is just about celebrating
celebrating who we are and the
importance of our culture while also uh
making sure that we
we we acknowledge the fact that so many
things have been taken from us
for me maroon's an important color
because it represents like like you know
when you grow up in a neighborhood the
folks there is like blood and like i
think for black culture everybody's so
closely connected and then like so much
blood has been shared around me and with
people i love and like the stories that
we're telling so for me like
that the use of that color is so
important and it also kind of connects
to the ethos of jordan brand because
they use team red so much in a lot of og
colorways
i think through sneakers
we have opportunity to start to change
the narrative of the world
like so the idea of building stores and
telling stories for me it's about
starting to change and reshape humanity
and the way people think about us right
like because uh there's a lot of ways
that we still don't get the credit for a
lot of the things that we do is black
folks that have opportunities as as a as
a as a race who exist in a world right
so for me it's about really just telling
the story of black excellence and
everything that we do is just about
following our journey the story of our
people and our culture and doing it in a
way is just so [ __ ] good that people
can't help but to start to look at us
differently